so often in life when we think about
change we're constantly fixated on the
destination
if you were to drive under that
condition you'd probably get in an
accident because you're not paying
attention to what they call the way of
the way and how do you remain in your
presence we go back to what we started
with be conscious when you're eating be
conscious when you're talking to someone
be conscious when you're having some
kind of a of a get-together a gathering
I am in this Gathering isn't this
Gathering interesting it doesn't have to
be anything more than that these are
really practical ways of being in what
we call you and I in this conversation
presence which means that you have to be
present in each moment along the way
trusting that the destination
is ahead of you